pestel et qu'on va rencontrer des
étudiants points disponibles pour
répondre au téléphone
surtout le matin est ce que on a des
personnes qui nous accompagnent en 12e
aux touristes une campagne électorale
est une opération bien orchestré on veut
clichés soient vus entendus pour ça ça
prend des journalistes
or comme les autobus nolisé par québec
solidaire pour transporter des
journalistes évident pour l'instant cela
sur lupine pas mal la garde rapprochée
de manon massé il n'y aura pas de
journaliste comme tel
à la conférence de presse mais il faut
faire comme s'il faut faire comme si on
allait vous c'est démodé pop sous
c'est vrai si on voulait juste des
médias enfin pour ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui le stelle chardon château
était attendu tard le pas du tout c'est
l'âme argentine
québec solidaire sort de sa zone de
confort effet brièvement campagne à la
campagne dans la région natale de manon
massé l'idée de voir si parti peut faire
des récoltes ailleurs et dans son jardin
cultivé ou centre-ville de montréal à
tous - puis planter quelques semences
[Applaudissements]
richmond une circonscription et mais je
faisais un bon une bonne candidate
on s'attend pas à faire de l'anadipp à
percer si on aime faire une annonce en
en agriculture bon parce que c'était la
place d'à côté du village natal de manon
il ya plein de monde qui sont venus voir
la conférence de presse
moi je m'attendais pas à ça prouve que
justement québec se lasse pas juste un
parti montréal et on est assez
impressionnant quand j'ai demandé à
l'équipe de manon massé quel type de
musique devraient se retrouver dans ce
reportage sur les coulisses de leur
campagne ils m'ont dit trouve quelque
chose de jeunes et de brancher comme du
valeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
car manche et l'équipe de q est-ce les
probablement les jeunes ça fait sans
équivoque
tout comme renault pour arriver saint
pierre s'occupe des communications
l'autobus
beaucoup d'entre eux ont fait leurs
premiers pas dans l'action politique
pendant le compte en érable dans les
employés on doit être une dizaine qui
viennent le la grève du tanking en étant
même groupe qui suivent depuis ce temps
là on a progressé ensemble on a
commencéà
à militer conte d'une cause de fiscalité
mais au final c'est durant au fur et à
mesure de la grève progrès c'est ce
qu'on voulait cet hôtel société
différente une société plus juste qui
devint par la suite
évidemment le seul parti qui propose un
vrai changement dans société quebecor
c'est québec solidaire
alors quand j'étais jeune une fois n'est
pas coutume québec solidaire déroule
cette fois-ci au lunch santé que fait
préparer l'équipe habituellement
aujourd'hui on veut permettre à manon de
manger le plat qu'elle préférait enfants
du petit lait est un type au vinaigre
j'ai rarement vu des gens qui sont
insensibles à son charme parce que c'est
vraiment quelqu'un de chaleur c'est
vraiment une personne chaleureuse
il a ré à la fromagerie c'est surtout
pour ça permettra man o man c'est de
toucher les gens ce qu'il fait au sens
propre de façon très spontanée
[Musique]
on paye corps est celle du plat comme
l'autobus et en garde partagée c'est
gabriel nadeau dubois qui prendra la
route le lendemain non masse et elle
rentre à montréal se préparer pour le
débat avec un objectif assez clair c'est
parfait pas de la chance
[Rires]